la réunion dans l'océan indien une île
paradisiaque qui attire chaque année 500
mille touristes dont beaucoup de
français
ils viennent pour découvrir ces paysages
volcaniques d'une beauté à couper le
souffle mais aussi des marchés colorés
et garni de produits exotiques mais les
joyaux de l'île de la réunion
ce sont celles à bondo turquoise protégé
par une barrière de corail et ses
quarante kilomètres de plages de sable
fin pour elle les vacanciers sont prêts
à faire des milliers de kilomètres et
les surfers qui enchaîne les vagues en
ont fait leur paradis mais depuis deux
ans la peur a gagné toute l'île on l'a
appris cet après-midi un surfeur a de
nouveau été attaqué par un requin sur
l'île de la réunion
âgé d'une quarantaine d'années l'homme a
été grièvement blessée au pied droit et
à la main par l'animal alors qu'il
surfait à saint leu dans l'ouest de
l'île malgré ses blessures il a tout de
même pu regagner la plage où il a reçu
les premiers soins
ce soir ses jours ne sont pas en danger
à la réunion c'est la troisième attaque
depuis le début de l'année la semaine
dernière un surfeur est décédé après
avoir eu la jambe harrachis celui qui
sème la terreur c'est ce prédateur le
requin bouledogue surnommé ainsi à cause
de son apparence trapu et son nez
arrondi ce monstre des mers peut
atteindre trois mètres cinquante de long
parmi les espèces de requins il possède
la mâchoire la plus puissante
depuis plusieurs mois une douzaine
d'attac a eu lieu à moins de 50 mètres
des côtes
le requin bouledogue s'est rapproché des
plages et ce n'est pas un hasard
ce qu'il attire ce sont les déchets
charriés qui se jette en mer
l'urbanisation accélérée de lille a
provoqué une augmentation des ordures
que les autorités peinent à traiter mais
ce n'est pas tout pour protéger le
littoral une réserve marine a été créé
le long des côtes
elle constituerait un parfait
garde-manger pour ce prédateur
aujourd'hui 500 spécimens rôderait dans
les hauts de l'île alors chez les
sauveteurs de la réunion le requin
bouledogue est devenu une obsession
nous sommes à boucan canot sur la plage
la plus meurtrière de lille ici le
requin bouledogue a frappé à trois
reprises deux surfeurs sont morts en
quelques minutes et un autre a été
blessé
niveau 2 après thomas au niveau du haut
niveau de la patère à la zone de soeur
sylvie maîtres nageurs sauveteurs depuis
sept ans
depuis que les requins bouledogues ont
fait leur apparition elle des limites
avec ses collègues une zone de baignade
très strictes jamais à plus de 20 mètres
du bord de plage pour surveiller les
nageurs sept chefs de poste dirige six
sauveteurs dont vous pensez quoi
aujourd'hui par rapport aux mets à
orange meignanne par rapport à la houle
la visibilité
ce jour là les conditions de baignade
sont relativement bonnes
il y a un peu de houle mais le fond de
l'eau est claire
malgré tout les sauveteurs kadri en
permanence la zone de baignade en bateau
pour détecter les approches de requins
font pas de bruit pour apprécier la
visibilité sous l'eau alors en général
[Musique]
début de journée avec le soleil dans le
dos qui se lève à l'est montagne on voit
on voit bien comment voilà maintenant le
plan d'eau au pouvoir bien au fond
depuis les défilés chazottes et
toussaint et en fin de journée lorsque
le soleil passe devant commence à faire
briller le plan d'eau on patrouille
vraiment observer
on ne peut pas plus voir du band en plus
de sylvie et de ces patrouilleurs en
bateau des vigies installés en hauteur
ne quitte pas des yeux ses eaux
turquoise
ils sont équipés de jumelles et de
lunettes polarisantes qui a tenu les
reflets du soleil à la surface de l'eau
leur rôle donné l' alerte à la moindre
tache sombre qui se rapprocherait le
dispositif est conséquent mais sur cette
plage la profondeur atteint rapidement
les trois mètres largement suffisante
pour un requin d'ailleurs ce jour là
sylvie reçoit une alerte inquiétante à
un couple qui viennent nous voir
apparemment il aurait vu d'un aileron au
niveau de capot marque pour les faire
une pâte richard dunne s'il vous plaît
ok terminée alors il ya un couple qui
est venu nous voir aussi allant toujours
ai vu un aileron ne savent pas c'est
sanaa le ronde de farrou un aileron
d'euros car parfois sa voiture et qu'il
ever qui lève la dorsale et donc à ce
qu'il fasse passer que j'ai demandé à
mes collègues allaient faire une photo
sur zone de que les gars en vigie en
chaise soient vigilants aucune idée
c'est vous et discuté au niveau ce cap
homard maison il ne nous a pas dit plus
qu'ils ont vu un aileron
l'aileron a été aperçu à 700 mètres de
là s'il s'agit bien d'un squale il peut
être là en quelques minutes
mais pour éviter un mouvement de panique
chez les baigneurs sylvie décide de ne
pas les évacuer pour le moment donc là
mes collègues étaient voir et
effectivement il y avait le temps dessus
donc ils ont vu une tortue certifié ils
ont bien observé
donc les gens ont dû avoir honte à la
tête de la tente où sortir et concrétise
on penser à un requin
c'est ce que cette façon au quotidien
mais après on sait pourquoi on fait ce
métier
le danger il est pas la patte d'envié 0
y a pas de risque zéro donc à ce moment
là à nous de bien surveiller de faire
preuve de fair price quand ça arrivera
en début d'après midi les conditions
météo vont changer les premiers rouleaux
se forment et rendent la mer beaucoup
plus attrayante pour les enfants mais
aussi bien plus dangereuse
sylvie est obligé d'intervenir les
enfants venaient accrochez vous la
particularité c'est que quand ça du coup
il ya de la houle à ça génère un courant
donc les gens qui sont dans le courant
là en ce moment qui retire au large et
donc il faut qu'on soit vigilant par
rapport à ça et il y à un autre problème
les vagues agite le sable au fond de la
mer et l'eau devient de plus en plus
trouble les requins peuvent approcher
sans être vu sylvie décide d'alerter
immédiatement les vacanciers en hissant
un drapeau qu'on ne trouve qu'à la
réunion moment ça veut dire que les
conditions sont réunies pour avoir pour
avoir des requins potentiel les
conditions sont que yelle la houle là où
commencent à rentrer la visibilité aller
moins bien donc c'est tout ça qu'on dise
la fameuse robe orange requins et si on
devait ici la flamme rouge ça veut dire
ça voudrait dire que avocats étaient
signalés et observer quand le drapeau
requin est hissé la baignade n'est pas
interdite mais tous les nageurs sont
appelés à la plus grande vigilance
d'ailleurs chez les touristes ce drapeau
ne passe pas inaperçu attention
gardez drapeaux et puis c'est vrai qu'on
reste vraiment que au bord
myriam 38 ans est né à la réunion elle
ya passé une bonne partie de sa vie
aujourd'hui elle habite à l'étranger
mais revient chaque été sur cette plage
avec ses enfants rafaela et gabriel plus
jeune elle se baigner en toute
insouciance mais ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui
la plage de toutes les vacances de
l'enfance on est là tous les week-ends
sont âgés eux mêmes loin au large
derrière la piscine plein dans les
récifs quand la mer est calme
enfin il y avait plein de façons
maintenant je passe très longtemps qu'on
plonge plus là et on n'a jamais vu de
même ni grosse vague là où les tournages
leur carnet pourquoi depuis les attaques
de requins le surf et la plongée avec
tuba ont été interdits sur cette plage
quand elle vient avec ses enfants myriam
les autorise à jouer dans les vagues
mais ne les quitte pas des yeux car les
requins sont capable de s'approcher tout
près du bord c'est ici
la base de quoi mieux je sais qu'il
reste au bord qui a pas de va pas aller
nager donc nickel toi qui vas pas nager
ce vent qui n'a pas de planche de surf
ou de mort et y'a pas de soucis il y a
deux ans un des sauveteurs de boucan
canot tu es mort à cet endroit
il n'était pas en service ce jour-là et
surfer sur les vagues en plein
après-midi le requin ne lui a laissé
aucune chance
son corps n'a jamais été retrouvé
il a été emporté au large
une stèle a été dressée en souvenir de
ce jeune homme est aussi d'une autre
victime des requins
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la baignade s'est bien passé
sylvie peut souffler un peu mais à la
réunion
les squales ne sont jamais bien loin
le lendemain en début d'après-midi une
attaque s'est produite sur une plage un
peu plus loin une plage non surveillée
sous cette bâche une partie du corps de
la jeune fille que les autorités
viennent tout juste de récupérer
[Musique]
l'attak a été d'une rare violence
une adolescente de 15 ans se baigner
avec sa soeur quand elle a été happée
par le requin c'est la première fois
qu'un requin s'attaque à un baigneur et
non un surfeur les gendarmes bouclent le
secteur
je
dur dur à quelques dizaines de mètres de
là ce restaurateur a assisté au drame et
au repêchage d'une partie du cadavre par
un pêcheur
les deux jeunes filles est en train de
se baigner il y en a une qui est remonté
et l'autre s'est fait happer bas le gars
il est redescendu tout de suite avec son
bateau pour essayer de retrouver quelque
chose et il a ramené ce qu'il a pu
ramener quoi la jeune fille venait
d'arriver de métropole pour passer trois
semaines de vacances avec son père elle
nageait avec un masque et un tuba non
loin du club nautique où son père
travaille
l'adolescente n'était qu'à trois mètres
du bord c'est la première fois qu'un
requin attaque aussi prêt à 2,3 m a
publié la donc habituellement les
enfants s'amusent sur le bord comme ça
sur le sarm regarda jusqu'où le sable
par ok derrière cette vague là c'est que
après là donc les gosses ils avaient
l'habitude de jouer là comme ça
maintenant ce qui est grave c'est qu'il
ya un requin arrive à ce niveau là faut
plus aller dans la mer maintenant
voilà sur l'eau un ballet de bateaux
s'organise
les autorités ont lancé une traque aux
requins leur objectif tuer l'animal et
le récupérer pour procéder à des
analyses
ces bateaux de pêcheurs partent
sillonner toute la baie de leur côté les
sauveteurs tentent de récupérer le corps
de la jeune fille
hors de question qu'il soit rejeté sur
une plage
je prends gauche point one
sylvie participent aux recherches pour
se donner une chance de capturer le
requin les pêcheurs ont truffées les
fonds avec des centaines d'âmes sont ces
recherches sont nécessaires pour que la
famille puisse faire son deuil
mais pour les sauveteurs cette mission
est difficile à vivre
bah nous ça nous touche parce que ce
soit des gens qu'on connaisse ou non se
met à la place de la famille parce qu'on
sait que ça peut être nous une attaque
de requin c'est brutal c'est la nature
c'est voilà c'est une attaque et un
sauvage par une super 15 ans donc on est
tous nous mêmes par an donc
un froid dans le dos mais bon après
c'est vrai cette métier on a nos métiers
puis on fait ça avec tout leur compte
quand aulas pour tes cordes et le
soutien aux familles a rien qui
[Musique]
aucune zone n'est négligé et pour
réussir les sauveteurs décide de se
laisser guider par les courants toi ça
commence à me manquer tête avec ça va
pour ramener vers le bois se mettre en
dérive
pour voir le courant
balkan éventuellement s'il ya des restes
on va voir dans quelle direction les
aurait pu tuer pendant que les
sauveteurs longe la côte à terre les
gendarmes continuent à sillonner la
plage au cas où la mère rejetterait le
corps les recherches vont durer deux
jours mais resteront infructueuses le
reste du corps de l'adolescente ne sera
jamais retrouvée il y a trois ans sur
ses plages de rêve de la réunion un
surfeur a bien failli aussi laissé la
vie il était venu passer des vacances en
famille
aujourd'hui il vit dans le sud de la
france
retour en métropole à martigues à
quelques kilomètres de marseille
eric dargent est un miraculé
hong kong
âgé aujourd'hui de 35 ans éric porte une
prothèse à la jambe gauche
tu veux mais d arranger tu peux ranger
déjà ton jouet faux frère éric n'a pas
perdu le sourire mais il a laissé une
jambe sur l'île de la réunion
parti en vacances avec sa femme et ses
deux enfants ce passionné de sports de
glisse a croisé sur sa route un requin
alors qu'il surfait
il n'oubliera jamais cet instant où tout
a basculé
quand c'est arrivé j'étais assis sur ma
planche bougeait pas j'attendais une
vague je n'ai rien vu venir pourtant le
temps était calme il n'y avait pas de
vent donc s'il y avait quelque chose qui
avait bougeait autour de moi j'aurais vu
et donc le requin est vraiment venu
m'attaque et par dessous il quand j'ai
senti quelque chose finalement c'est pas
une violent une douleur très violente
c'est un petit peu pour expliquer
souvent explique c'est un petit peu
comme si la jungle on est happé un
rocher ou taper quelque chose de dur et
j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui s'accrochaient à moi et j'ai donc
j'étais assis sur ma planche et à ce
moment là j'ai penché la tête pour voir
ce qui se passait et c'est là où j'ai vu
le requin j'ai vu que c'était un requin
bouledogue aussi toute la forme d'une
tête arrondie et à ce moment là bas je
me suis défendu j'ai commencé à taper
sur le sur le requin j'ai frappé le plus
fort possible sur sur sa tête chez g et
puis j'ai senti qu'il commençait à
avrillé vers le fond est en fait la
chance de la chance c'est que ma jambe
s'est arraché et est à ce moment là j'ai
senti que ça lâchait et moi j'ai pas vu
tout de suite que que que vraiment ma
gens qui m'avait arraché la jambe je
suis content j'ai continué appartient
donc là il ya vraiment tout cette
angoisse de mourir je me suis resté au
fond j'ai j'ai lutté au maximum geiger
mais j'ai hurlé j'étais pas très loin du
bord donc j'ai pu rejoindre le bord pour
moi j'ai eu vraiment ce moment de
flottement je savais pas si j'allais
mourir si j'allais vivre et puis je me
suis raccroché voilà cette image de mes
enfants la femme qui est à côté pour moi
je pouvais pas y rester
eric a été amputé d'une jambe depuis cet
accident il a dû réapprendre à vivre
avec ce handicap
ton père sa jambe ne perd pas que ça
jean où on perd aussi sa place quelque
part d'hommes forts de deux donc c'est
ça on a besoin aussi de reprendre cette
place important ces vacances ont
longtemps hanter sa famille mais son
combat pour reprendre le dessus force
aujourd'hui l'admiration de ses enfants
c'est bien parce que j'avais baissé les
bras toujours continuer je commençais à
m'habituer beaucoup parce qu'il n'est
il est amputé depuis longtemps depuis
des années bientôt trois et maintenant
c'est comme s'il était comme avant il
est très courageux que nous l'avons
toujours et les mois seront qui l'aimé
bien comme ben pas eric n'a jamais
abandonné sa passion de la glisse
depuis l'attaqué du requin il s'était
toujours promis de remonter sur une
planche
grâce à sa prothèse il surf aujourd'hui
des vagues comme avant
[Musique]
eric a été l'une des premières victimes
d'une longue série d' attaque de requin
sur l'île de la réunion depuis son
accident les requins bouledogues n'ont
cessé de se rapprocher des plages et les
écoles de surf de l'île ont fermé les
unes après les autres pour limiter les
drames les dernières écoles de glisse
embauche deux fois par semaine des
gardes du corps un peu spéciaux des
hommes grenouilles
ok c'est ok tout bon on dansera sur la
fin sur la fin du pic les plus jeunes on
sera dans l'art forme et y en aura deux
un petit peu plus en l'ouverture pendant
que les élèves seront sur leur planche
ces plongeurs qu'on appelle vigie
requins vont rester sous l'eau philippe
à droite et ses collègues ont pour
mission de détecter l'apparition
éventuelle d'un squale
là on va on va regarder la qualité de
l'eau bon là c'est vrai ya pas de
couverture nuageuse
donc c'est déjà un atout ya pas beaucoup
de houle donc je pense que ça va être
une session dans de bonnes conditions
leur travail est très risqué alors pour
parer à la moindre attaque
philippe dispose d'un fusil harpon muni
d'une flèche en titane pour transpercer
le requin chaud des outils à la mesure
de ce qu'on va faire c'est des requins
très très malin et on le voit placide
avancer tout doucement et puis en une
fraction de seconde c'est une ça devient
une fusée en égalisant à l'extérieur
c'est cool à prix sont ils sont même pas
3 mètres de nous donc dès qu'on rentre
dans l'eau on voit un petit peu ce qu'il
en est au niveau de la visibilité donc
c'est clair que la ja praticiens comparé
au niveau de la surveillance les surfers
qui attendent la vague sur leurs
planches sont aveugles
philippe et ses comparses seront donc
leurs yeux sur ces images on constate
que le dénivelé est important les
surfers évolue très vite dans trois
mètres de profondeur
ils deviennent alors des proies faciles
pour les requins sous l'eau
philippe a une visibilité supérieure à 5
mètres une distance suffisante pour
réagir en cas d' attaque sans armée en
tout cas c'est un requin qui s'approche
de la zone neutralisée nourrissent que
rien pour l'instant
après il ya toujours des risques ici sa
part de responsabilité mais sur les
barrières de corail qui nous protège
pour en finir avec les attaques de
requins et faire remonter la
fréquentation touristique
l'état a lancé un projet de grande
envergure et les associations de
surfeurs se sont organisés pour mieux
connaître leur adversaire ils ont décidé
d'implanter des puces sur 80 squale afin
d'identifier les zones à risque et la
fréquence des passages
ce jour là guy gazeau et son fils alexis
prépare une expédition en mer tous deux
sont bénévoles pour la ligue de surf et
surtout des plongeurs reconnu dans
quelques minutes ils vont implanter des
émetteurs sur des requins on n'achète
que de l'epr
voilà il est fixé par un petit d'art qui
se trouve au bout d'une d'une cordelette
voilà c'est ça c'est ça rentre dans la
peau du du requin et ça se retourne
derrière
et donc voilà ça navigue avec lui ça ne
gène pas seulement avec cette petite
embarcation
alexis et son père par te rejoindre un
gros bateau situé à quelques kilomètres
des côtes
à bord quand il tombe sur un requin
bouledogue
voilà comment il procède pour le marquer
d'abord il le pêche à l'aide d'un à part
une fois que le squale a mordu à
l'hameçon ils le retiennent dans un
certain périmètre
alexis plonge alors en apnée à une
dizaine de mètres
pour tirer les metteurs sur le requin
avec un fusil harpon
[Musique]
une fois que le requin est touché alexis
et son père le remonte à la surface pour
prendre des mesures précises taille de
la mâchoire espacement des dents toutes
ces données vont servir à étoffer la
carte d'identité de chaque spécimen
contrairement aux apparences cette
femelle de 3 mètres n'est pas du tout
endormie elle peut mordre alexis à tout
moment alors pour éviter de se faire
attraper la main les membres de
l'équipage maintienne sa bouche ouverte
à l'aide d'un crochet
mais bon
alexis et son père peuvent maintenant le
relâcher en le détachant au niveau de
ses nageoires et de ça que le requin
bouledogue va vivre désormais avec son
émetteur pour le suivre à la trace
alexis et guy vont maintenant installé
ces récepteurs à proximité des spots de
surf 109 268
9h40 là on a un récepteur qu'on va aller
installer pour pouvoir détecter le pote
de surf juste derrière au moins sur
l'appel divers savoir ce qui s'y passe
et 7 n'arrive à comprendre un peu une
fois encore cet appelée east chevronnés
va descendre à 10 mètres de profondeur
pour poser le récepteur sur cette ligne
de flottaison
il enregistrera désormais tous les
passages des requins marqué dans un
périmètre de 500 mètres pour se protéger
d'une attaque alexis et son père plonge
toujours à deux et guy tient toujours un
bâton pour repousser le squale une
protection qui peut sembler dérisoire
[Musique]
alexis et son père vont en profiter pour
remonter un récepteur poser précédemment
ils vont recueillir ces données à bord
de leur embarcation est l'abbé toyer
d'avoir 90 par rapport à la une d'un
moment où on a posé la balise on a trois
semaines d'enregistrement de données et
ça nous permettra de savoir quels sont
les requins qui marque et qui se sont
passés dans la zone pendant ces trois
semaines les limites de ce matériel là
c'est la prévision
on ne peut pas dire maintenant si dans
cinq minutes y aura encore des requins
ou s'il n'en a pas c'est impossible
tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est analyser
ce qui s'est passé avant impossible de
détecter en temps réel les passages de
requins mais depuis deux ans les
récepteurs ont tout de même livré des
informations intéressantes
les requins bouledogues visiterait la
côte surtout pendant les mois de juillet
et août
cela correspondrait à une période de
reproduction
autre détail il circulerait surtout le
jour et resterait en moyenne une
trentaine de minutes dans la zone du
littoral
[Musique]
les autorités finiront elles par
interdire la baignade sur toute l'île
difficile à envisager dans le tourisme
est important pour la réunion
lille n'en n'a certainement pas fini
avec les drames
pour l'heure la population tente de
panser ses plaies
comment ce jour d'hommage à
l'adolescente
la dernière victime des requins
avant nous enchanter
nous permettait de libérer de l'assouvir
de passion d'être libre aujourd'hui m
ce jour là plusieurs centaines de
personnes s'étaient rassemblées pour une
cérémonie aux fleurs qu'il espère ne pas
avoir à revivre
[Musique]